und jetzt schauen wir auf unseren
Bundesgesundheitsminister und den neuen
wiederkehrenden corona-regeler sind
diesmal geht's um die Regeln im Zug
maskenpflicht sie wissen im Flieger
aufgehoben aber in der Bahn da bleibt
sie natürlich bestehen die maskenpflicht
und es heißt ja die medizinische Maske
die reicht jetzt nicht mehr im
Fernverkehr aber das Problem ist jetzt
das kommt jetzt neue hinzu soweit können
wir alle noch folgen ausgerechnet dass
Robert-Koch-Institut also das Karl
Lauterbach ja untergeordnet ist das
warnt jetzt vor übermäßigen Tragen von
ffp2-masken was sollen wir jetzt damit
anfangen bildmeinung Chef Philipp
piathoff hier bei uns im Studio bei Bild
live also ich als Bürger als Konsument
dieser lauterbachschen Regeln wem soll
ich jetzt glauben was geht
das ist jetzt völlig egal wem du glauben
sollst es geht eigentlich nur darum was
du zu tun hast dann so sieht das Karl
Lauterbach hervor ab dem 1 Oktober gilt
ffp2 maskenpflicht und Zug das heißt
wenn du von Stuttgart nach Hamburg
fährst dann musst du ca 6 Stunden lang
ffp2-maske tragen natürlich darfst du
sie für einen Schluck Wasser kurz mal
abnehmen der Zug pünktlich ist sonst
länger natürlich absolut wenn man Glück
hat und ausnahmsweise dazu pünktlich
pünktlich ist das Problem ist nur dass
eben die Experten von Karl Lauterbach
die Experten vom Robert-Koch-Institut
food eigentlich auf ihrer Website davor
warnen dass man zu lange
ffp2-masken trägt denn da gibt es
beispielsweise arbeitsschutzverordnungen
und da heißt es man muss die Maske also
je nach Arbeitslast nach 75 oder nach 90
Minuten für 30 Minuten absetzen das ist
im Zug natürlich völlig unmöglich wenn
man eine lange Strecke fährt da steht
auch also auf der Seite des
Robert-Koch-Instituts steht das ist
keine Studien dazu gibt was denn mit
Menschen passiert die zu lange oder die
einfach lange ffp2 Maske tragen weil das
natürlich weil diese Masken einen
höheren Atemwiderstand haben als ganz
normale medizinische Masken also sprich
die ganz normalen blauen Masken die man
sonst so im Alltag sieht das heißt Karl
Lauterbach lässt uns eine Regel befolgen
vor der die eigenen experten warnen und
warum das so ist ist völlig unklar aber
man will ja halt ein Zeichen setzen
überall sonst fallen ja die Maßnahmen
und Karl Lauterbach hat vieles ja nicht
wieder geschafft einzuführen aber bei
einer maskenpflicht konnte sich offenbar
durchsetzen unterstützt leider von der
FTP tja und jetzt müssen wir im Zug alle
ffp2-masken tragen obwohl die Experten
unsere Regierungsexperten davor waren
stahlobsurd wunderbar ich freue mich
schon auf den Herbst und auf den Winter
Philipp pioto vielen herzlichen Dank
über das
corona-maskenwirr war an dieser Stelle
[Musik]